oui chérie
ouais merci ma puce je t'appelle
d'exalead là-bas
jolie que reviendra à mon pote c'est ta
copine non c'est erin walton la fille du
juge walton
tu as dit au chauffeur est nouveau ouais
pourquoi
devra béton pairs pour être sûr
[Musique]
tous en position
qu'est-ce qu'on fait papa ours et bébé
ours on les supprime jaune a dit que
vous êtes un béret vert appelle son père
à bas les rides
papa bc3 tout de suite sa corde vous
avez à faire une équipe de talents
hautement qualifiés je tiens ta fille
si tu ne fais pas ce que je te demande
de faire quelque chose d'horrible va lui
arriver
il aurait dû prendre ton colis est
parent est vite fait
hommage à
21 ans il est responsable de la mort
d'une cinquantaine d'hommes il est
dangereux et n'hésitera pas à vous tuer
tu veux comprendre tout ça non tu viens
juste de tuer ce cas il allait tuer
c'est pas vrai je t'avais dit par dire
qu'on abandonne personnes pas vrai
[Musique]